I was talking to somebody about the
podcast and they were saying oh yeah you
you really uh go at it with Corley and
yeah I said well I guess there's some
passive aggression there and he said
well I'm picking up on the aggression
but not no passivity no no no I could do
with a little position I'll try I'll try
and work some of that in let me ask you
a question sure are you excited when you
come into work and you're going to do
this or are you just sort of neutral or
are you actively depressed
full disclosure in the early days I was
nervous oh you were nervous of course I
was yeah I don't know I'm Sonam
obsessian nice did I see what you're
doing doing the old Switcheroo I've been
nervous too will she be cogent
she's not here if you have rum and
gummies for breakfast
they're called rummies yeah uh no it's
funny because I I I'm always in a real
good mood when we come in to do this me
too I'm I'm happy to do it it doesn't
feel like work and when people tell me
they enjoy the podcast I'm always kind
of delighted because I think Oh that's
oh that's that's nice that you like it
because it's really fun to do it's crazy
it's really it's crazy it is gravy
because at first I didn't really know
how to uh you to you and Sona had a
rapport I was a little afraid because I
didn't know how to kind of trade in in
that yeah because you were an interloper
yeah yeah I think that's what it was
yeah we had we were sort of established
and really uh riffed well with each
other and it was organic
um and you you know were forced into the
situation uh in a way that was just
wrong yeah and I mean once I found my
voice on how to really Stick it to the
Man yes that's when I really started to
feel like there's it's a three-way
energy going on that I now I really
enjoy coming here well you know it's
funny uh I was you know saying earlier
that uh you know joking that you were
forced upon us you were not we're
delighted to have you because you're an
extraordinary voice in the podcast
Community which I didn't even know but
every time we have people come on the
show they're like well I know Gorly from
and then they start listing all these
you know Fez weekly and the Magoo report
and the jub jub bower with Winky and
doodoo they start listing all these
podcasts Simon McGee takes it at home uh
you know incredible list of shows that I
didn't even know about the cuckoo hour
with girls girls just for the record The
Fez one is bi-weekly okay bi-weekly all
right but anyway you're very well known
in that world uh Subterranean strange
world yeah and if that oh please anyway
I'm not you are you are people know you
and they go like oh my God it's corally
and I go like okay you know really and
then they start listening again all the
podcasts that uh that that you are a
part of you know I got a mining hat come
with me
um with Matt Gourley uh gorley's Wall of
Shame uh these are sounding better as
you can keep
Report with my daughter's nicknames uh
yeah but anyway and then they go on and
on and on about all the wonderful shows
that they've heard you do and I didn't
realize how many you've done and how
your different animal voices and what
there's one where you talk about you
know all kinds of stuff that happened in
Roman history oh you wish
I do wish actually I'd listen to that I
like a good History Podcast but anyway
it's it's very nice I mean it works in
podcasting what can I say I made my
bones inside a sentence ever uttered I
made my bones in podcasting I got in in
2011. oh 2005 right I cut my teeth you
were knee-high I cut my teeth in
podcasting when you were barely shaving
height this reminds me of housing in Los
Angeles because I grew up uh in the
Boston area
and houses are old yeah there and so you
know the house I grew up in was built in
1900 and that's just standard wow you
know it's that's that's pretty standard
for that area of you know right outside
Boston but uh and then there are houses
from the 1800s they're houses from the
you know 1700s around Boston some from
the 1600s full of witches yeah seriously
um populating the whole area so I live
in Los Angeles and you buy a house here
and I remember we had some problem with
our house
and there was like a leak a pipe was
broken or something from a root and a
guy came and he was looking he dug down
he was looking at it and he shook his
head and I said what's the problem
you're like well you know the pipe broke
uh that goes into the house and you know
so that's that's got to be we got to get
in there and put a new piece of pipe
because to see this tree root broke it
and I went huh he said you see this much
and he went well
we see it from houses like this from the
mid 2005 2006 is Jesus and he was kind
of acting like
you know when you get a house that was
made before Obama's first term you run
into problems like this what are you
talking about yeah they act like well
you got one of these
you got one of these houses from from
the third season of Gossip Girl
you got a 2006. wow we don't see many of
these anymore because what happens here
is people people out here buy a house
that was built in 2011 and tear it down
yeah and build a new house because
they're like oh my God you should have
seen it when we got it don't get me
started it's a shame it is stupid it is
too bad I know you live in uh a magical
home a gingerbread home no you do it
looks like a gingerbread home it's
lovely it's it's lovely and parts of it
are made of gingerbread I know no no
marzipan well good good improv skills
again graham cracker no well that's your
improv no this is not improv no this is
you berating me no and I I'm forced to
defend myself The Improv team of Conan
and garlic and let's get started Conan
takes the stage hey everybody and uh oh
here's my friend here we no I sure love
working in this Comedy Factory don't you
love I mean I'm sure love working in
this candy factory
Gorly are you okay you wish you know
all that stuff I was saying about
excited to come in here it's gone Corley
we sure have a difficult boss here isn't
he funny isn't it weird that we have a
difficult boss who's half dragon half
ape no oh am I also 80. no well that's
how you say no you did you hear yourself
saying no I need Sony here this is this
is why we need Sona couldn't be here
because sona's on a book tour yeah
because that's what happens when you
hire an assistant that refuses to do her
job she writes a book about it it's a
big hit and she goes on tour
welcome to America oh man this is
fantastic I can't believe I gotta do
this yeah yeah well let me think uh I'm
sorry you are a great improviser I'm
sure you are no one puts out an old man
no like you do no no no no no no no no
comedy no jokes no jokes I want to go
home all right here I am with my comedy
partner Matt Gourley give us a
suggestion no
came to see the podcast that's his
suggestion no I learned it all from him
no